[Music]
on this Sunday night from Dolphin
Manitoba a city seeking Solace tributes
to lifelong friends and family members
lost it's impacted so many as a small
community Waits For answers
one of us has
seen
very close calls multiple times a day
the near misses and the trauma of
long-haul truckers who drive the
trans-canada highway
breakthrough or breakdown in Beijing the
U.S Secretary of State kicks off high
stakes talks in China
and the latest blow to budget flights
what westjet's shuttering of sun wing
could mean for you
and the silver sleuth my father never
spoke he never never talked about
enemies the German curator returning
heirlooms that vanished during the
Holocaust
National with Donna Frieza
in Dolphin Manitoba prayers on this
Sunday for those who died for those who
survived but are hospitalized and for
those who responded to the crash that
killed 15 people and injured 10 others
this is a small close-knit community and
the grief is widespread
it's impacted so many probably everybody
in Dolphin knows somebody involved
good evening and thanks for joining us
we are in Dolphin tonight and for those
grieving and seeking answers church
services today could offer only
companionship and prayer there were 25
people on the bus involved in the
collision with a transport truck they
ranged in age from 58 to 88. the
investigation into exactly what happened
on the trans-canada highway near
Carberry is still underway some of the
churches today welcome journalists
Marnie blunt went to one of the services
and spoke to lifelong friends of those
who died
praying mourning healing and trying to
come to terms with unimaginable loss A
somber Sunday morning service at St
George's Orthodox Ukrainian Church in
Dolphin within the community of St
George's everyone here probably knew
everyone on the bus
I'm not aware of everybody that was on
the trip but I can assure you that I
know
each and every one of them and the
trauma has hit everybody very very hard
and some directly affected by the
tragedy I unfortunately lost a close
family friend and she was my godmother
people coming together to lean on one
another and their faith during a time of
Devastation the temple is the hospital
for souls and bodies it gives us energy
perspective direction for the week that
is coming and all of its problems well
let them rest in peace whoever did pass
away God be with them
according to the priests some people on
board the bus lived at St George's place
a retirement complex with ties to the
church they lost their mothers they lost
their brothers and they lost their loved
ones it'll take time lots of people have
loss in that way but time heals Our
Father in heaven Hallowed be your name
more prayers for those affected over at
Trinity Lutheran Church which has served
as a support center this week for
grieving families they are going through
a grieving process that's different than
anything they've ever been through and
this past year has been trying for the
area because there have been so many
deaths it seems one thing after another
the community still dealing with the
pain of another tragic crash in March
that took the lives of three dolphin
teens and another from carvery when
their vehicle collided with a semi on
Highway 5. tragedies that have the
community coming together during dark
days I just want to send a message to
the family that the whole Community is
praying for them
hoping that they can come through the
trauma
as many are coming together to cope and
grieve the loss of their loved ones
we're learning more about who some of
them were including nakonesi whose
granddaughter confirmed she was a victim
on the bus crash she's remembered as an
incredible Baba to eight grandkids and
five great-grandkids with a six on the
way her granddaughter saying her love
for God was wholehearted and her impact
she made on people's lives is unmatched
as you can see this horrific event will
leave a lasting impact on so many
families many of which may find some
comfort in each other and their memories
that will live on Donna
all right Marty blunt thank you Marnie
the police investigation into how the
crash happened is still underway at the
intersection where it took place tire
marks are still visible where the bus
and the transport truck collided that
intersection on the trans-canada highway
has long worry drivers who have to cross
it often tonight Nitro lay looks at the
history of accidents and near misses at
the spot where so many died last week
slowly meticulously accident
reconstruction experts take pictures
measure skid marks and take a closer
look at the horrific scars left on the
road and shoulder of the trans-canada
highway oh my gosh it's been three days
since a handy bus carrying seniors on
their way to a casino burst into flames
after a dramatic collision with a
semi-trailer the driver of the bus
remains in hospital he's one of the
co-owners of quality Care Transit which
only recently added the bus to its Fleet
while considered a safe and essential
vehicle for giving seniors access to
travel drivers say they're not without
their issues our vehicle is similar to
the vehicle that was in the accident and
there is a definite blind spot in in our
in our vision when it comes to the right
side of the bus and you know we have
always taught our our drivers to open
the doors just like you would have a
school bus or Transit bus open the doors
to get better visibility because there
is some blindness on that right side
drivers and locals are very much aware
of the dangers of Crossing or merging
with the trans-canada highway it can
certainly be a White Knuckle experience
but the statistics support the idea that
drivers specifically at the Carberry
intersection have adapted
with 22 vehicle collisions recorded over
the last Dozen Years an average of under
two per year and before last Thursday's
tragedy there had only been one fatality
recorded over that period
so is this a highway issue or a
mechanical or human failure Ralph
Merrick has thought about those same
questions often over the past seven
years the other fatality at the Carberry
intersection was his son-in-law
Christopher patzer a 24 year old with a
young daughter could never figure out
why he would
cross that Highway
without stopping or
not sure exactly who was at fault but it
it's always been very puzzling as to how
that happened Merrick was himself a
truck driver who thought he'd seen it
all but his son-in-law's accident
forever changed him ever since then
every time I go by that intersection I
put my four-way flashes on so if I have
a light on a roof I put that light on
particularly that particular
intersection because of that
this latest accident was a stark
reminder of why he takes safety so
seriously microlight Global News
Winnipeg
a support line for grieving families has
been set up the number to call is
204-647-5058 and a support center is
being run out of the dolphin Lutheran
Church for those who feel they need it
I'll be back from Manitoba a little bit
later right now Farah Nasser is here
with the rest of the day's news Farah
Donna not good news for air Travelers in
Canada looking for cheaper alternatives
as we reported yesterday sun wing will
no longer be a choice its new owner
WestJet will be absorbing sun wing
aircrafts into its existing Fleet over
the next two years and this is just the
latest example of a Canadian Airline
brand disappearing swoop met the same
fate just last week Sean OSHA is in
Toronto with more on what this means for
your next trip
[Music]
Flyers especially heading to warm
weather destinations in winter
toronto-based sun wing is a popular way
to get there but its new owner has
confirmed the airline brand is
disappearing the die was cast when
WestJet was permitted to acquire sun
wing months ago by the federal
government sun wing was created two
decades ago starting as a tour operator
then acquiring its own planes to meet
increasing demand WestJet will add Sun
Wings aircraft to its own Fleet having
several Brands to manage is not ideal
from a operating perspective but from a
consumer's point of view there is going
to be less Choice the question is going
to be you know which markets does
WestJet decide to reduce services on the
Canadian Airline Market is dominated by
Air Canada and WestJet earlier this
month WestJet announced plans to shutter
its discount swoop brand and with the
sun wing name disappearing that really
leaves just Porter Air Transat and Ultra
low-cost carriers flare and links you're
not going to have three flights from the
three carriers going from Toronto to
portuguay Arthur Toronto Montego May on
a Saturday morning in January you're
going to have one maybe two I'm
confident that this is going to result
in higher prices or service the federal
government allowed the sun wing sale
with few conditions this was a very uh
ill-advised decision by the government
to approve the acquisition something
that the government went against the
recommendation of the competition Bureau
swoop will remain a brand until October
and WestJet hasn't announced a timetable
to eliminate sun wing competing Brands
within the same corporate family just
doesn't exist one industry Watcher says
a stronger WestJet may try to price out
flare and links on common routes at
least temporarily be on the lookout for
its aggressive pricing uh and some
aggressive markets that WestJet is now
going to go after and he says more
consolidation may be in the flight plan
we're just heading into the summer
cool
um batting down the hatches shuttle Shea
Global News Toronto
secretary of state begins a high-stakes
trip to China
coming up the hopes and reality to find
common ground in a critical bilateral
meeting
new evidence suggests that Russia blew
up that huge Dam in Ukraine causing
deadly flooding in the war-torn nation's
South according to a New York Times
investigation the dam which lies in
russian-controlled territory was
destroyed by an explosion in a
passageway that runs through its
concrete base the investigation also
suggests that Russia would have had
access to the Dam's designs and known
its weaknesses since the Dam's
destruction on June 6 flooding has
displaced thousands of people in the
region at least 35 have died
despite sour relations between China and
the U.S both countries are calling the
start of a two-day meeting between their
foreign ministers candid and
constructive U.S Secretary of State
Anthony blinken is in Beijing the first
such visit in five years as Redmond
Shannon reports the agenda will mostly
involve trying to rebuild some
much-needed trust between the two
superpowers
Anthony blinken is the first U.S
Secretary of State to visit China in
five years a gap caused by covid-19 but
also by Icy relations this meeting with
foreign minister chin gang postponed
from February after the shooting down of
the alleged Chinese spy balloon the
moment that we are in right now is
perhaps the lowest point in bilateral
relations since the normalization of the
relationship an era that began in 1979
but in advance of the meeting Joe Biden
seemed eager to play Down the damage
caused by the balloon incident I don't
think the leadership knew where it was
and knew what was in it and knew what
was going on the long list of disputes
on the agenda likely includes human
rights spying the production of fentanyl
ingredients microchip technology trade
sanctions scientific cooperation and
perhaps most sense of all Taiwan here's
a perfect example of where clear
communication is necessary because I
don't think the Bible Administration has
any intention of supporting Taiwan
Independence re-establishing channels of
communication is absolutely necessary to
reduce the risk of miscalculation and
crisis statements from both sides called
the first of two days of talks candid
and constructive presidents XI and Biden
are likely to meet in the coming months
at the G20 in India and at the Asia
Pacific Summit in California this event
likely aiming to smooth over some of the
large cracks in advance of those dates
also if we can put a period to the that
era and they're willing to move forward
that is a major achievement the U.S says
it expects China's foreign minister to
make a reciprocal visit to Washington in
the near future Redmond Shannon Global
News London
had stolen silver heirlooms headed back
home German Raider helping a family get
back with the Nazi stole from their
Montreal father
several German museums are returning
family heirlooms stolen from Jewish
families during the second world war to
the descendants of their rightful owners
the objects are mostly silver and some
of them passed down for Generations now
it's painstaking work that requires a
considerable amount of sleuthing Mike
Armstrong explains how they're doing it
and what it means for one family getting
their father's item back
when William Bergman passed away in 1986
he left questions unanswered he's buried
in Montreal the city where he raised a
family but that family never knew much
about his life growing up Jewish in Nazi
Germany my father never spoke he never
he never talked about any of this
bergman's son Stephen now lives in the
U.S and though his father's gone he's
learning more about his life thanks to a
message out of the blue that at first
seemed like a hoax at first I was
apprehensive I'm always concerned that
somebody's scamming you on email
whatever's going on so I looked up the
information and it was the national
museum of Munich
that message came from the office of
Matthias vinegar he runs a program at
the Munich museum with the mission to
return silver objects stolen from Jews
by the Nazis to their rightful owners
it's really important to try to find the
families and in my view and give back
the objects though systematic
confiscation in 1939 the Nazis brought
in a so-called silver tax Jews were
forced to surrender jewelry and precious
metals to pawn shops thousands of items
were melted down and turned into gold or
silver bars to support Germany's war
machine but some ended up in museums and
might be the spoon your grandmother ate
with they aren't Priceless works of art
some are quite simple but they were once
family heirlooms vinegar's Museum had
112 stolen items and since 2019 has been
trying to find their owners there's been
detective work going through pawn shop
records and then scouring ancestry sites
and social media this Candlestick belong
to member of my family up to now we have
been almost always had the right person
when we when we had such a trial and we
almost never failed it's nothing fancy
Bergman had some emotional moments when
he first held the cup sent from the
museum it was seized from his father
just before he escaped Germany it's a
Kiddush cup used in blessings to
sanctify the Sabbath and Jewish holidays
bergman's done some research and says it
was made in the 1870s and had likely
been in his family for decades yet he
never knew it even existed a total
surprise so to hold this now and I just
wish there's a lot of questions I have
from my father someone dies the Museum's
success tracking down descendants has
surprised vinegar himself he hopes to be
able to give back every item by the end
of the year in fact he's planning a trip
to Ontario this summer they're going
above and beyond well Bergman may have a
trip North as well he's looking at
donating his father's cup to the
Montreal Holocaust Museum this City
where he rebuilt his life after escaping
Germany with 50 cents in his pocket as
time goes by I realize how difficult his
life was
and and this just brings all that up
Mike Armstrong Global News Montreal
[Music]
it's life on the highway we're back to
Donna freezing
er's face
[Music]
welcome back to Dolphin Manitoba the
trans-canada highway is a Lifeline
across this country we take it for
granted now but outside of our cities
roads especially paved ones were
relatively rare until the 20th century
the trans-canada highway traverses 10
provinces from British Columbia across
the Prairies Ontario Quebec Atlantic
Canada and into Newfoundland not
including the offshoots like the
Yellowhead and Highway 17. the main
route runs
7821 kilometers and is the world's
fourth longest highway I know it well
because I've driven vast stretches of it
and I grew up on a farm next to it here
in Manitoba anyone who did knows what
life on the highway is like
it is truly the open road west of
Winnipeg the trans-canada highway
stretches across the Prairies like a
ribbon offering the possibility of trade
and travel
and no one knows the road better than
truckers I worked at this truck stop
when I was 14 and this weekend it hosted
Manitoba's professional truck driving
championships Dave Henry has been a
trucker for 35 years what went through
your mind when you heard about the crash
I was I was sick to my stomach because
every one of us has
seen very close calls multiple times a
day the highway is Canada's artery
inside all these vehicles are truckers
delivering what we need to survive
tourists exploring the country families
taking vacations and seniors going on
bus trips a reminder some road trips and
in tragedy this is where I grew up on a
farm right next to the trans-canada
highway the road only has a stop sign
the farm is actually intersected by the
highway and like so many people here we
crossed it multiple times a day with
farm equipment vehicles and his kids on
the school bus anyone who drives it or
lives near it knows what it means to
cross it it's not talked about much but
many truck drivers Dave says carry a
heavy burden a lot of truck drivers
suffer from PTSD have you had
near-misses yourself
I've had more than near misses yes I've
had
I've had accidents I've had a lot of
I've I've seen too much one that
involved a crash was a car driving up
fast beside me lost control
and
wiped out in front of my truck and a
slipper I have nowhere to go
and all I see is this girl's face
looking at me as she's sliding towards
me and I hit her there
and I'm I'm thinking I just killed that
girl
you know and I see that car goes
spinning off on the side
and I'm watching it in the mirror
because I'm like don't roll over don't
like be fine
the girl he says was not killed but
close calls like that haunt long-haul
truckers and Henry now an advocate for
mental health is thinking about both
drivers involved in the Carberry crash
get the therapy you need
talk it out with people
even the one that's not at fault he that
person is going to have a lot to deal
with this has affected both of these
drivers for the rest of their lives and
when we see truckers driving down the
highway now what should we be thinking
about them give them space and be
thankful that they're out there trying
to move goods for
everybody it's not an easy job it's not
an easy job and they're trying to do
their job and get home safe to their
families and their loved ones and we're
all trying to do that something to think
about as we take to the open road across
this vast country
that is global national for this Sunday
I'm Donna Friesen our thoughts are with
those who are grieving and those who are
looking for answers for now from Dolphin
Manitoba thanks for watching and have a
lovely evening
[Music]
thank you